（ヒ）あー、だいぶだいぶ
ほら、同じ髪型。ふふ　（ヒ）はは
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーと、
（ヒ）ヒロキです。（多分）
というわけで、心霊スポット！
東京の有名どころですね。
（ヒ）もう東京じゃないね、もはや。
（ヒ）全国的に　（は）全国的に有名なんですか（ヒ）有名　有名
僕基本的に静岡の心霊スポットはほぼ攻めたんですけども
まあ東京に来てせっかくなのでこちらの心霊スポットも行ってみたいなということで
ちょっと今回ヒロキさんと一緒に行ってみます！
（ヒ）よしぃ　（は）はい
朝の４時１０分です。（ヒ）はっはは
時間が・・・　なんか４時４４分てすごいヤバい気がしません？
（ヒ）やばいね　（は）やばいっすよね。
今回行く場所をちよっとまだ説明してないですね。　（ヒ）うん
今回行く場所なんですけども、２０１７  東京や関東地方で一番怖い肝試し心霊スポットはどこ？という
そういう系の記事があったんですけども、
そちらの、ツー！　（ヒ）うん！　（は）2番目
“吹上トンネル”という場所でございます。
で、どういう場所かと言いますと　（ヒ）うん
東京都青梅市にある古いトンネルです。
『ここでは昔、近所で茶屋を営んでいた親子が
強盗に襲われ、母親は店で殺され、娘はトンネルへ逃げ込んだものの、
そこで捕まり殺されたという話があります。　（ヒ）うん
で、それ以来、夜中にここを通ると、娘の霊が出現すると言われている』と。
まさに良い時間ですね。４時ぐらいなんで。
場所的には、新吹上トンネルに入る手前に、右へ入るこう道があって、　（ヒ）うん
そこへ行くと旧・吹上トンネルがあります。
（ヒ）なんか車止めがあるんだよね。　（は）んんん
ちゃんと止めれる場所があるので、　（ヒ）んー
そっから歩いていけるらしいです。
でなんか周辺には小さなトンネルが多くあるらしくて、　（ヒ）うんうん　（は）ま、結構スポットとして有名らしいでございます。
では、早速向かっていきましょう。　（ヒ）YOSHIKI（よし）
すごい東京の心霊スポットっていうと、僕違和感しかないんスよね　（ヒ）どうして
なんか静岡とかだと田舎が多いから、　（ヒ）うん　（は）山道とか　（ヒ）UUUM（うん）
意外となんなんか怖いんですけど、　（ヒ）UUUM（うん）
この都心ていうか都会の中にあるスポットってどういう感じなんだろう・・・っていう　（ナビ）ポーン オヨソ300メートル先ネカ・・
（ヒ）あぁ、確かにね
思い出はいーつーも　（ナビ）ポーン 続イテ右方向デス
きーれーいーだーけど〜
（ヒ）今のまっすぐでよかったかもしれない　（は）マ！？（マジの略語）
結構でもやばいですよ雰囲気　（ヒ）いい雰囲気だね〜
ヒロキさんの血液型当てていいですか？　（ヒ）ほいよ
Aですね。　（ヒ）はいはずれ
Oですね　（ヒ）正解
やっぱりな。一発でわかりました。　（ヒ）へっへ
（ヒ）はじめくんは〜　あっむずいな〜
（ヒ）どっちかだな〜　BかABだな？
（ヒ）AB！　（は）正解です
（ヒ）うぃ〜　（は）ぅえ？本当に知らなかったですか？　（ヒ）うん
すごい、ABっぽいですか？　（ヒ）ABっいね〜
（ヒ）うへっ　（は）ヒロキさんの〜スマホのキャリア当てていいスか？　（ヒ）うん
ヒロキさんauですよね？
（ヒ）なるほどね？　（は）いや、違うなdocomoですね？
docomoでファイナルアンタで　（ヒ）ファイナルアンタ？
（ヒ）正解　（は）よーしやっぱりな　（ヒ）んっへっへ
もう近いですかね
（ヒ）ああ、急になんかきたね　　（は）やばいな、これは
（ヒ）もうちょい行くと出てくるはずだな。
（ヒ）トンネルだよね　（は）トンネルですね
（ヒ）右右右
（ヒ）ある？　（は）ここ止めれます？　（ヒ）あ〜ここだ　これこれこれ、多分。
はい、というわけで着きました。こちらですね。
（ヒ）COCO2（ここに）　（は）で、ここに停めれると。
（ヒ）そうそうここここ。　（は）はぁ〜
（ヒ）左側にあるトンネルが、新吹上（トンネル）
うんうんうん　（ヒ）で、この右奥にあるらしい、旧（吹上トンネル）が。　（は）なるほど。
（ヒ）よし、行こう。　（は）はい。
いきますか。　（ヒ）よし。
ここですね。　（ヒ）ここ。
これが、（新）吹上トンネル　（ヒ）新ね　（は）新　（ヒ）うん。
これが現吹上トンネル。　（ヒ）そう。新　（は）新。こわ
え、なんか、すごい鳴いてません？　（ヒ）めちゃ怖
え、本当になんかやばくない？なんでこんな鳴く？
（ヒ）すごいね
（ヒ）気持ち悪いくらい鳴いてくれるね。
あ、明るいっスね。　（ヒ）うん。
はい、というわけで着きました、こちらです。
旧吹上トンネル
ん〜、明るいねぇ
これ結構イージーモードじゃないですか？　（ヒ）ねぇ
こんなの、もう朝飯前っスよ　（ヒ）ウオッフッフ
（ヒ）やば へっへっへ
（ヒ）ハヘッ ヘッヘッヘ
フラフラしてきた
うわ〜こういうの怖いっスよね〜
（ヒ）ほんとだ
なんか、ガスり方がすごい。すごいガスり方が。　（ヒ）すごいね
いやぁ、見えてないな。
え、割と怖いっすよ。　（ヒ）割と怖いね。
誰かポイ捨てしてる。　（ヒ）うーん。。　（は）ラキスト吸ってますよ　（ヒ）ははは
デュくっ
あっ もう後ろ見えない。　（ヒ）ほんとだ
結構深そうですね、そして　（ヒ）そうだね　（は）怖いよ
なかなか恐怖ですよね
もう終わりです。 わ〜いこいこいこ　（ヒ）せゅふふ
（ヒ）ははっ
（ヒ）はっは
（ヒ）それ、なんの跡なんだろうね
よくわかんないっすよね
（ヒ）さっきかららずーっとこう
なんだ？
えっ
今聞こえました？
（ヒ）聞こえたよ
ゴーンって聞こえませんでした？　（ヒ）もちろんもちろん
（ヒ）え、なにあれ
え、待って何今の
え、ここだけだよ
これ場所（がまずいのでは）？
わかんないわかんないわかんない
えっ、でも
（ヒ）はじめくん？　（は）すいません
（ヒ）聞こえた聞こえたもちろん　（は）あー、もうダメだ　俺もうダメだ　もうダメだ
（ヒ）多分撮れてるよ、今普通に　（は）撮れてますよね　（ヒ）後ろからでしょ
（は）なんかこっちからきましたよね。　（ヒ）きたきたきた